welcome to this video round five
coverage of the same field cup the
tournament has seen great chest so far
fighting chance in all rounds there were
no boring short drawers or anything this
round is no exception three games of
fighting chest um long games so I need
to be careful that this video is not
getting like two hours or something and
yeah let let's start right away let's
start with T'Pol off against mdl Maxine
by Sheila Grove um yeah Maxime is the
only play with fifty percent after four
rounds yeah koala is running away with
it with four out of four and yeah uh
Sheila Graham fifty percent to pull up
on minus one but after two losses to par
love has won a game so his sort of
started yeah trying to certainly want to
want to follow up on this win let's see
what we get we get the night off which
is no surprise that all this is MV else
main opening against efore and we get
them the night off with Bishop e3 and
five very well known and popular line
with opposite side castling yeah now
black decides to play the move a five
this is a move that in recent years has
become fashionable and it's very
interesting in a way strategically at
first them it looks somewhat strange as
it gives up the Beehive square of square
that this a typical neither of porn on a
six was meant to protect but it has some
very concrete ideas why term really
shouldn't allow like to push even
further with a 4s then also Queen a5 SM
is possible why does basically yeah
let's know he's not forced but almost to
play a for you can also play Bishop b5 I
think after which black normally plays
something like that fighting for those
squares
again but a form is the maintenance and
now we see one black point he gets this
Bishop and this night I'm sorry to be
form yeah this is a quite nice outpost
it's not as secure outpost as b5 as at
some point c 3 might happen but this is
a long way this is not a way and ya
black ass is active night which controls
d5 and his let's play on the seaford so
this is an interesting way to play king
be one Queen c7 I mean all this looks
looks fairly standard to me at least I'm
not a one a four player or a night off
player so it's not like I can no I can
ya tell you anything super on ya like
like an expert view here I only know
that this this looks fairly normal we
should be five ook cagr playing on the C
file group g1 near also this this looks
normal with g45 white has gained some
space maybe getting some tech later it's
not like white is storming blacks King
side quickly the night on h5 looks funny
but it looks any any advances here like
h4 h5 and sometimes can jump to a form
yeah it's important to see that with
bishop on e6 and night on before a night
jump to d5 is not really dangerous at
the moment black can safely take this f5
yeah that's an interesting way to play a
very typical way to play black gained
some space here on the Kings side and
why this is basically forced to take
with the pond you don't want to like to
be in a situation where you can even
choose if he wants to advance probably
not ought to take so why it took on f6
and the night recaptured yeah pretty
much the only sensible move in this
position there's some
this is probably not not advisable
giving up the pawn so takes takes Queen
g2 yeah threatening a direct made and
now night h5 yeah I'm not too sure about
the next couple of moves and there is a
one very critical position that arises
on move 24 in six moves and it's it's
it's an interesting question where black
should should should deviate because I
can tell you the slide spoiler in about
six move blackiston in severe trouble I
think here everything should still be
okay but it's a very very difficult
position to assess what why does doing
now this is very logical really to pile
of nope late night see one this is a
case where we have the typical situation
where your worst plays piece should be
improved the night on b3 is just not
doing anything it's looking a bit at a
five but really the Queen on c7 is
always covering that but other than that
the night is only looking at at squares
or it doesn't do anything night see one
is a good idea yeah you have ideas to
put it on d3 maybe you can exchange the
before night under good circumstances or
you can maybe sometimes put the night on
e 2 so that you play F form at some
point the night in any case is better
than won't be three yeah black and I'll
play Bishop f6 this is in a way setting
up what what's coming up in a couple of
moves so maybe we can question this move
it's it's possible maybe here the black
should improve somehow i'm not sure
however how maybe Luke c7 or something
maybe we should look at what's what's
coming up we should f 693
and now my Sheila graph took on d3
quickly he was aiming for the coming
position and this is an interesting
position where you obviously or where we
will see there is some some debate how
to how to assess it it seems that black
should avoid what's coming up and maybe
you should play the night back to c6
that cannot be great but maybe it needs
to be done what he did is he captured
and played a night reform this was the
whole idea of course sales at the
beginning of all of it to put the night
on f4 and open up this diagonal ok right
now went 95 of course and black captured
there is no no big question about that
and this is interesting this position
let's put this on the board fairly
normal move covering d 6 + f4 NC three
it was quite interesting that this
position when it when it came up i was
watching a little bit of the live
broadcast and commentary was provided by
by jennifer shahada and mostly a yeah so
Sarah one who's of course yeah
world-class grant must say well not at
the moment by ido rating but he was in
the in the top ten for a long while in
the 80s and 90s and he's an excellent
positional player so he really has
excellent strategic judgment and that
was very surprised when this position
came up that he thought that black had a
very good position and because well my
judgment was that wise should white
should be very very much better so it
was the complete opposite what I thought
and well normally he simply right
because he's the far better ha better
player I was somewhat relieved to see
that the computer agreed with me and
gives white a very substantial advantage
it seems that in fact really white is
indeed much much better here and black
has has some some very very substantial
problems to solve we will look at it
in the we look at it when we look at the
course of the game it's still not clear
to me how black should should avoid all
this maybe maybe somewhere here but it's
difficult I really don't know what else
is unite f1 looks really normal and what
should he do yeah maybe maybe really we
need to look look early am yeah well the
compounds to play this and and it gives
white not much but this definitely
wasn't the idea therefore it's it's a
very difficult move to play this is the
computer suggestion quite surprising
okay but as Cena see the IDM after this
there is this attack jump if now Bishop
g5 it's very very strong too to put it
mildly if this is d 67 and then black
gets gets totally clobbered okay yeah it
is it is it is somewhat I'm confident
comfortable oh I'm not sure really yeah
i think my expertise in the night office
maybe a little bit too too limited to
really give a great advice eerie yeah
maybe look f7 something like that let's
look at let's look at the game and not
spend so much time on it as mentioned
this position I thought white should be
much better because black does not have
any plan at all I mean he has this this
Bishop only five but it's just looking
at the c3 bone and unless why does
somewhat some are blundering into some
sacrifice here on c3 this is just
nothing White's king is perfectly safe
on a to a Viva not be three is totally
safe if white wants and the only white
can maneuver here you can do something
on the G file and he can reposition his
pieces to attack the somewhat weak pawns
on the queenside I think topple off does
an excellent job here he plays some you
Queen f2 looking at this now maybe queen
a seven and then attack those pawns b6
we should a six rook to be eight here
there was an interesting moment in this
position to pull off also I went wait
just one move earlier in this position
the answer could have played Bishop c4
which would have been a good EDM yeah
simply threatening this this big
discovery yeah this is of course and
made check me I cannot take it you
probably must do this and then Bishop b3
this was a very strong regrouping
intending later Bishop b5 rook b5 and
then the green invasion comparable to
what happened in the game it was maybe a
little bit quicker unless you see this
is what what he's doing in the game rook
to be five and then he's repositioning
later the bishop so the rook wants to be
on b5 and with this Bishop see form of
earlier he could have gotten this a bit
quicker yeah here white is just very
nicely improving his pieces slowly queen
is coming to enter and black is totally
tied down to his weaknesses as I
mentioned on the on the start of this
structure plucky has no play whatsoever
he managed to to exchange a bit but it
does not change the general evaluation
White has invaded on the light squares
and this is also a big key problem for
black the light squares are very weak
well why does not have any any weaker
squares really this Bishop is just a bad
piece I mean it looks nice only five but
it's never doing anything on a only if
white summer blunders into a piece
seconds you through this piece I was
making some sense otherwise it's just
sitting there doing nothing yeah and now
this is a very nicely played by at
Apollo begins more space and now he also
activates the king very typical you can
easily just move up the king here
yeah King to be three activated it's
very frustrating for black to see in
this position that even an opposite
colored bishops endgame which normally
gives good drawing chances even this
would be probably a loss yes why this
just sorry just invading here and
grabbing the pawn if you imagine this
position without Queens and rooks even
this probably is a win with white just
entering a queen side and this is the
big problem here why does slowly gaining
space and space yeah just just getting
in there Queen c5 wasn't the toughest
defense he could have probably played
them quinta da to prevent Juke g5 but I
think in the long run this is probably
not a defensible position yeah y term
can can even consider to play something
like this maybe if you move the King up
but ok you should try to exchange Queens
first if possible it's just a very
passive position yeah this is not
helping now the rook is even even
getting involved ya mook g5 Luke be 8th
route f5 and in this position with equal
material um yeah maxima resigned
resigned the game it it seems to be an
early resignation but it's it's really
it's really not a position that you can
can defend in any case i can give you
just one sample line if black plays
quincy 8 trying to exchange the Queen's
yeah why does just doing that and puts
us put this rope here yeah now White's
plan is simply wants to put the bishop
here and rook b7 picking up the pawn
maybe it could end can continue like
this let's say black defense this Bishop
here should be five and now wyd wants to
go here and play rugby seven at the end
he picks up the whole Queen side Black
is totally paralyzed he can play b5
check something like that
King to a four maybe where do you go to
a for even yeah to a four why not black
cannot take this is check this is a maid
check check check mate yeah so black
needs to retreat and then we just I can
be played before yeah I guess we can
even start with before him yeah takes
takes and the beep on will win the game
black ass is just totally totally
paralyzed the mistake must have been
somewhere before this this structure was
coming up but hard for me to determine
what did what it really was but ok as we
saw during the commentary this position
was was not easy to to to evaluate as as
we saw that Sarah Juan was very
persistent in claiming black was black
was was perfectly ok and even preferable
um so um it's it's easy to believe that
also Rashida graph was Sir was wrong
here and maybe thought that ok I
shouldn't be too bad here with this
bishop and so on but it turns out to be
a totally passive position ok this was
the first game and a great win for to
pawn off was now back on fifty percent
good very good achievement after he lost
the first two games that looked like a
disaster but now with to win sees his
back back in the tournament ok the next
game we're going to look at his Aronian
cards and let me pull up my analysis yep
our own Ian Carlton here we go let's see
yeah this is a duel of two players on
data on minus one right level is on
minus 1 right am I am I correct with
this what did he do in the earlier
rounds well mungus definitely is on
minus one he lost one and played played
some drawers yeah let's let's do get the
game
not wasting any more time we have this
somewhat we had move order this b6 is
interesting yeah even Knight f3 is just
think not very common this move and in
the top level with white somehow
committing the night early I'm quite
interesting what what would happened if
if cards have played e6 he has a normal
move but he went b6 yeah he's playing
the Queen's Indian anyway and this way
this adds an interesting twist to things
yeah siege III was played Bishop g7 I
wish should be seven and ce4 it's
interesting c4 is quite necessary here
if white goes Bishop g2 then c5 is a
very a very good move for black it's
nothing nothing extraordinary but this
is a pretty good move now because well
white really does not have a anything
else then then capturing or let black
capture you cannot push d5 which you
normally I want to have available if the
bishop is already on b7 the best that
white can do is a transposition to a
slightly inferior version of the
Hedgehog something like this for example
this is slightly inferior because you
get the Queen out on d4 with the bishop
still on f8 so black is still a flexible
to sometimes put the bishop here for
example so this is why aronian played
c4m so that after c5 he has d5 very
important cards now could play six of
course but this is a transposition to
the Queen's Indian and to a position
that he's not playing really in his
repertoire in the Queen's Indian after
g3 is playing I was bishop a 60 and
sometimes Bishop before check he is
committed to Bishop d7 so he was
avoiding that and plays g6 funny move
but this is in fact very much playable I
myself had looked at this a bit and
from a totally different move order for
Knight f3 1b6 I have studied this a bit
and black despite its somewhat funny
appearance with this double fianchetto
black seems to be okay in this position
there is nothing terribly bad that can
happen to him want key idea is that if
white plays Knight c3 here black is
playing 94 and getting this this traded
very often it sometimes like this is
happening something like this is
happening and now black is playing
something like let's say d6 and c5 yeah
he needs to put something in the center
ultimately but he has a good pieces the
bishop on g7 is so nicely placed and the
bishop only for very often gets traded
on the long diagonal this is a fairly
satisfactory position for black Aronian
is playing rook e1 now this looks a bit
funny but the idea is that now black cam
is somewhat yeah short of a move he
needs to play now of course and night
efore is not a good idea as you're
putting it down somewhat prematurely
you're running into pins yeah something
like this that's that's not that
terrible at the moment but this kind of
pins can be annoying you want to have
something to exchange on c3 so sort of
black waits to till the night arrives
there he played e6 93 no 94 this is what
I was talking about you always want to
have this neither to be exchanged ok
this happened and Bishop g5 yeah Queenie
8 they are not much choice in yeah f6 is
very ugly Queen d2 d6 yeah auntie em
around here I think we can conclude that
may be why term is slightly more
comfortable due to space black I saw
ever very flexible there's nothing
terrible going to happen to him this
kind of structure can arise in the in
the Queen sinyun here the bishop is even
a bit better on on g7 than usual
me so white straight cm on one g7 and
now go some yeah now continues with the
typical maneuver Bishop 2839 f6 Jack
controlling the important light squares
in the in the center and now white plays
9h form I think ultimately this is not
not leading to much in the broadcast
yessir suggested Queen c3 which i also
like in a way I mean this is intense
Knight d2 and d4 the main point of white
playing Bishop h3 is to make sure that
this Bishop is not traded on the long
diagonal he wants to move the night away
maybe let's say this is what happened
let's say something like this now black
yeah probably c5 but if black is doing
nothing let's say then 92 we should be
seven e4 this is what white wants to
achieve he wants to occupy the center
and without trading those Bishop to keep
more pieces on the board and leave black
a little bit little bit cramped um
aronia tried something similar he played
night h4 the idea being to play f3 any
form however it turned out that this is
not leading to that much however black
black of course must be cautious in this
position we have a typical situation
there should be seven f3 and here black
m is is only really having one good move
this is probably a parent to a stronger
player but maybe not so much for less
experienced player black here absolutely
must play c5 everything else will not be
sufficient that the point is if you
place um let's say some some less
forcing yeah let's say rook c8 for
example then white we go efore and the
problem now is if you go see five white
has d5 which leads to a very substantial
point advantage and
sendspace advantage in the center the
bishop on b7 now is simply not a good
piece with this c5 black make sure that
after efore he's got the opportunity to
take to capture here and this is what
happened in the game rook the eighth now
we have a structure that is fairly
typical of the English opening and most
often arising from from the Hedgehog
this is six of the six rank set up here
black has achieved something is
exchanged dark squared bishop which
means that the dark squares are a little
bit to be content and we see this pretty
pretty quickly that like is getting on
those dark squares I think black has
equalized here there isn't really any
doubt that that he should be okay yeah a
five keeping the Queen posted on c5
before shouldn't happen so a 50 d 1 h 5
little space gainer here also making
sure that there's never never something
going to g4 group t3 doubling on the
default and b5 yeah and here here we
come to very very own very real
situation where I absolutely didn't
understand just going on at some it
happens quite often when I when I
watched those games yeah here aronian
the next move sequence was very very
surprising to me um here I thought um
yeah white definitely yeah I should take
on b5 I thought just take this and
continue from here let's save Queen d2
or something black definitely has no
problems but I thought it should still
be yeah okay for white around equal what
he played is he played b3 and after this
he captured with the B pony I mean
theoretically speaking you could think
about this but this is just a worse
version of the structure that structure
that we had
we had before oh yeah you can question
if this is happening an Audi 5m yeah
this is worse than before I thought you
should take on b5 he went with be three
and now took with the pawn which
probably it's not like fatal or anything
but it just feels like yeah sort of
giving up any any hope to to get get get
more in this game than then suffering
forward wrong as now you just have this
bad porn here on c4 on a light square
and the whole structure is is
comfortable for black anyway if blacks
got some time he made might get in 97 to
see 5 e 5 night coming to deform very
long term plans but he just has
potential in the better structure the
bishop on f1 is just looking at its own
taunts f3 e4c form so this is just just
comfortable for black probably it's
nothing serious but it's it's giving
yeah it's it's sort of giving giving the
the initiative away young we continued
with some some normal-looking moves
would be eight Queen deform yeah not not
clear what what why should do a ella I
mean other other than that move um here
interestingly contemplate queen e five I
was expecting a leaf I've really putting
this pawn on a dark square but it turns
out that this is fairly okay for white
it it does not look great with the the
bad bishop but those pawns are somewhat
vulnerable as well so I'm something like
this year if I hear something like this
like takes white always has this this
counter plane so it should be it should
be okay for him Queen if I this probably
just stronger it sort of provokes the
next move yeah white definitely
shouldn't take this is this is quite
clear
yeah at first you think okay well this
is a double pawn this does not make much
sense for black but it does in fact
those pawns control very important
squares and pluck here we'll get the
night to c5 and very long term will play
a 5 and this will undo the pawns while
the c-4 point is not going anywhere just
very comfortable for black a very well
known structure by the way this double
porn on the e-file that covers the
important square C on on d5 and d4 so I
think Queen takes d5 wasn't even
considered by a but aronian much he went
with F form yeah this is a move that
it's a bit impatient but I understand
that you really want to do something
maybe it was better to just sit and wait
with I don't know rook be 3 or up t2 or
something after F form um it seems that
black is getting something something
tangible nothing decisive but it did
he's getting somewhere here he had a
choice Carlton went for Luke c7
interesting move i was thinking more of
a five but it's it's hard to how to
evaluate if I forever also looks quite
good if we look at this something like
this route is six rooty 656 like take CM
also looks quite nice I mean something
like this is certainly better food like
how much better whom is not easy to say
black has got got better a better piece
coordination and will will enter here
not not a bad line and white of course
also can take after this for example um
fe de we have this coming
and this also looks quite good for black
who has the better structure and 97 as
the next move something like this yeah
note that c5 Luke c8 just just basically
drops the pawn um yeah it was already am
a convenient choice accountant went with
rook c7 which was also interesting yeah
now rook takes t6 I mean this is what I
ronnian played but rook takes t6 Bishop
before is also leading to a favorable
structure with the sea porn it's a pest
poem but also a week pawn this is just a
very one-sided position the night might
come to c5 yae for and black has chances
to infiltrate he went with this move and
now 98 covering d6 and trying to regroup
yeah why does just giving up this Pony
it's sort of couldn't stand to protect
it any longer yeah it's not clear to me
if you really needed to do that white
maybe also was okay with just just
shuffling it is a bit more comfortable
comfortable for black in any case
because of this weakness I know that
white looks to have a space advantage
and everything but he does not really
have any any plan he have available on
plus blacks got to be far the open farm
but okay this is probably not a mistake
or anything here after after see form we
around here we come to come to an
interesting an interesting situation why
displaying e5 now and if we look at this
it really feels like white has serve has
gotten some sort of compensation for the
porn I mean yeah he's activated his
Bishop this night is not great and he
has all of all of his pieces I active
this is an interesting rule in a way
that if you feel like you you are worse
and need to defend as long as all your
pieces are still working and have some
purpose it's very often the case that
you're not lost or in super serious
trouble and here white pieces are all
working and do something so it probably
shouldn't be a be a lost position or
anything I think white has very decent
chances to defend here probably but I
had a hard time to really figure out
where weather yeah how the game now
unfolded where where possible mistakes
on it's very very difficult to judge
they got some trade cm in that not clear
to me that white needed to allow that
but it's probably not not not a big deal
the pawn on c4 is still long yeah under
under some under some pressure or absent
under some pressure is the wrong
expression but yeah black has a hard
time to make any progress this is what
I'm trying to say yeah after 92 here in
this position Bishop c6 was played and
yeah maybe here maybe here we can we can
say that I ronnians play can be improved
you played night b3 and it seems that
well the computer is very persistent and
saying that this is just equal maybe it
is maybe this I mean if white is white
is sort of preparing the capture also
with with the rook and maybe there
really is nothing that that can be done
and this porn is probably going to get
lost now this is the calm suggestion
King III with with equal play
interestingly enough it's all depended
on some technical tricks what aronia did
night b3 also looks yeah looks okay yeah
you know the rookies attack but the
there is a technical detail here with
rook v8 maybe he misjudged something in
this line now played this now of course
black can never take as the rook hangs
on c5 and here maybe here there there
was some some mistake that he made in
his calculation now c3 was was a very
strong move like it some attacking on b2
still you cannot take I mean this is
just promoting the beep on so this
needed to be played and now rook to rip
to be five yeah interesting like here
has returned to the pawn but in exchange
for this big threat of a form yeah and
what should why do to to fight this is a
for IBM it's it's difficult really you
need to need to move this rock and he
went to see one black camp will gain the
porn anyway if you look at this may be
for example a four look at this one and
this is even less attractive keeping the
night on the board against this
dominating bishop so he went here and
after this we got the good old rook
endgame with an extra porn the extra a
porn yeah here we are in a situation
where this should be an yeah more
favorable for black than than usual or
in some comparable positions here black
has some the additional idea to protect
the porn from the side you have three
different scenarios with those a porn
extra a pawn or h4 end games um very
often it to the airport you have the
situation where this loop here on on b3
is on on a eight to support the pawn
from the back you could have the rook in
front of the pawn like here or you can
have fun the rook from the side
the best situation is from the back the
worst situation is to have it in front
of the pawn if you have an in front of
the porn it's very often a draw behind
the pawn almost always it's a win and
from the site you normally have very
good practical winning chances and this
is what what supplies i think to this
position Black has excellent practical
winning chances but if it is really win
is difficult to determine especially
with limited time and he I'm talking
about limited time in analysis not in
the game in a practical game it's very
difficult to defend I couldn't really
work out if ya how big blacks advantages
I can point out some things but it's not
really um yeah as great or comprehensive
analysis why does some playing I think
the the normal moves putting the King
here to h3 you don't want to be in a
situation where your king is totally
back on the first rank and causal plays
with g 5 which is an interesting
approach he wants to break up this the
structure on the on the King side and
creating further weaknesses i think this
is a means that is fairly typical here
white needs to capture look before as
mentioned he's protecting the porn from
the side it's not attacked at the moment
but white is of course inclined to keep
an eye on this porn yet here yeah hasn't
played played this move here we come to
the first interesting situation where i
don't quite understand white smooth but
i am really not not totally sure about
all this um aronia played this yeah
getting to this position where i
understand his rationale now whites rook
is very active and able to to keep
blacks King on the back rank this in
fact also looks very draws to me I mean
how is black going to to win this
position without is king
very hard to very hard to believe
however he also had an alternative to
the game continuation I thought that
also King g2 came into consideration
just them allowing black to take on g5 I
mean this position this position I
thought that this should be a fairly
easy draw but maybe I'm I'm I'm too too
optimistic here I mean normally all
positions with an extra porn on one side
where both kings are are simply a draw
but may be here with the e porn Black
has some practical chances I'm not sure
I mean this river will very likely be a
long and not very fun game but white but
I still think you should draw this um
I'm not saying that he that the game
continuation was was worse but I'm not
sure I mean normally it's it's better to
get rid of the the passer and let's say
yeah give gift the other side the extra
porn on the side where the king is still
have four three against two or two
against one on then to to fight against
the pass porn but still I mean here with
the black king cut off I still think
this should be some some decent drawing
possibilities but I what I'm not sure
really how I do should hold this we can
look at this a bit more maybe I'm taking
a more a more detailed look at this in a
further separate video I mean I've
launched this this instructional videos
that will be or that are on basically
daily now when there's not a tournament
coverage if there is a big tournament
i'm going to cover that but if there is
none i will post some instructional
video and maybe i will take up this rook
endgame again in such an instructional
video i don't want to make this
this is even longer we have from King
III now H for this is black side a must
get some sort of second weakness on the
Kings side and I really don't know how
should should white try to try to defend
here I mean around here I think blacks
are winning chances are pretty pretty
considerable the problem is that if we
look at this very often we come to a
situation he played King do three very
often we will come to a situation if
something like this is made you play it
looks a bit tougher then we we have this
we come to this where black is going to
get his King involved and maybe pick up
the upon and with two pawns um black
should win this I mean F&H porn is a
draw with some accuracy for the defense
but um yeah central point here I porn
eng porn should be a should be a win so
and then white cannot keep his pawn him
it's not more possible you will lose the
e5 pawn so this is a win for black yeah
maybe this is intact the problem that
white cannot avoid this scenario now I'm
not totally sure though in the game it
was fairly easy you went here a
three-wide cannot take because of this
well-known idea channel t he even kept
both parts but he went for this king
activation but black is just just
pushing his pawns and when he have
Aronian resigned so we have to first win
for the world champion here and pretty
pretty typical style from this sort of
not very much position he sort of round
out of this this this end game I would
like to give a clearer judgment how if
white could
better I mean I know that I definitely
would have gone for for this King g2's
King g2 thing to give up those pawns for
the a pawn but um yeah maybe he
considered his practical problems there
to be to be bigger but stay curious I'm
stick here is this should white be able
to draw this somehow yeah I need to I
need to look at this a little bit deeper
and maybe look at in a different video
this is going to be too long anyway so
maybe I'll pick this up in a in a
separate in a separate coverage let's
look at the final game of this round um
and this is of course my camera koala
the top US player nakamura not having a
great tournament he lost them he lost
one game against them against a pile of
a very unclear game and he now is
playing caruana was in having the best
tournament of his life basically with
the four out of four sensational result
so let's see we have a sloth and now
nakamura comes up with 92 that's a funny
little line not be too um I am recently
some weeks ago produced some more
episodes on our video series and I'm
doing for the internet chess club the
ICC I'm doing this in German language
presenting an opening repertoire for the
black player based on the sloth defense
and I discovered that this move really
was coming into into fashion and I was
surprised because it Trent is speaking
it looks a very inoffensive in a way the
other night is not particularly well
placed I think the main motivation for
this line is that yeah the other lines
don't don't give a white much also so
it's trying new things while Bishop f5
night h4 Bishop before this was also my
recommendation in the in the
video series um yeah black is developing
his bishop from c8 and yeah here we have
a situation where he's sort of offering
why to take it but if we look at this
this is not leading to to anything black
even as a choice you can take with the
night or you can take with the pawn
Knight take some has this nice idea also
to play a five now in this position
getting in Bishop before the capture
only four is really not leading to
anything additional leaders also the
pawn capture where you sometimes have a
very very much offside night Ian okay
why does playing a three-block went back
and now III yeah very often white also
flicks and queen bee three but he didn't
do the CM III b6 and now white when g3
this looks a bit strange maybe at first
but it's very often played in the
structure this position would be very
common in fact with the night being on
c3 yeah this is coming up from this from
this variation ya know this is the same
position but the night is on c3 in the
game it is on d 2 and this is of course
a very a substantial difference the
night is much worse on d 2 in comparison
so it's not quite clear to me what why
does hoping for in this position it
should be very very okay for black um
yeah there should be seven played a
three yeah maybe i'm having a look at
the before squared preparing before at
the right moment 97 yeah like it's not
castling yet wants to wait until the
situation here on the King side is
clarified white now captures on d5 and
black took with the C porn
he takes is also possible but he
probably didn't want to face the idea of
a wide central expansion with e form
which is not possible now but in the
long run this would be White's plan but
see Texas is just very solid ya know
like em where I decided to take and play
Bishop to d3 here also f4 as possible
yeah trying to prevent this ephi firm v5
move you know it's however also
weakening the foursquare was just a very
principled yeah well that said its
mother was a parting of the ways after
Bishop d3 now Black Plague e5 yeah he
opened the center against White's
against white some bishops but yeah
White's peace coordination is not very
good at all note that this is a huge
difference that the night is on d2
compared to see three with the with the
knight on c3 e5 would be a very
questionable move as why then is much
quicker and coordinating his pieces in
the game we got this and now an
interesting an interesting situation
arises here kawana could have played
quite enterprisingly with Bishop d6 this
was pointed out also in the broadcast
queen bee seven engine and then just
Queenie some playing a plane for
compensation giving up the pawn it's
probably true that like has a very
decent compensation for this s white it
has all those clumsy pieces and a
somewhat weak structure but Caruana
decided to play in a more solid fashion
you played Queen c8 just covering b7 now
we see an interesting moment here the
next move is probably pretty clear to a
good strategic player but it's still
interesting maybe you can treat these
little exercise why to play the the best
movement in strategical way to play okay
I'm putting it on the bone now night to
be one this is by far the best moving
the
what absolutely must relocate is night
the night on d 2 is terribly placed and
you really wanted on c3 you can have a
look you want it here to put this
pressure on d5 note that black is doing
the same thing he wants to get the night
to to c6 and we get exactly that we
should be three Queen d7 this is a
situation that or this position is
pretty much rising very logically from
this Quincy eight move and how to
evaluate this at first glance you think
that occasion Dwight be comfortable here
it's a symmetrical position of course
but white still has the bishop Pam and
he does not have any big um let's say
drawback in his position is no bad piece
or anything um yeah I was thinking that
white should be maybe a very very much
slightly better but it's not so easy to
to suggest a setup or plan an idea that
I was having here is to to somehow
improve this d3 bishop if we look at the
position the d3 Bashar p.m. it's not
attacking anything it's just sitting
there and I was thinking maybe it's an
idea to do something like this maybe
rook here Queen back and then Bishop be
1 to a 2 and maybe this is an idea
Bishop to a to pressure rising d5 and
maybe if all this is said and you are
very well coordinated you can even think
of pushing on the King side slowly to
try to get to the d5 pawn maybe this is
an idea we see that Nakamura is putting
it playing a different setup it's
playing it like that and now we see that
kawana is playing this very nicely he's
relocating his f 69 the f6 night was
purely a defensive piece looking at the
d5 pawn and he wants to activate it to
e6 where it puts some pressure on deform
he also puts this Bishop on f6 looking
at d4 so black has managed a very nice
regrouping
g5 was an interesting move yeah possibly
preventing any f4 ideas I'm not sure
that f4 was any dangerous but he played
this anyway also he prepared this g6
King g7 possibly allowing rook h8 and
also taking their five square under
control the next couple of moves are
probably very critical for this game um
it it seems that this before idea played
by nakamura I think I mean you wanted to
do something remotely active I think so
we went for before but I'm not sure that
this helps him very much he is pushing
those pawns we see ya b4 b5 but I
thought that mostly it leaves behind
some weaknesses b5 is potentially week a
three or all those squares somewhat weak
now and I'm not sure that white has
gained so much from that so yeah tough
very tough decision if this was if this
was any good he now played um Bishop e3
um interesting suggestion here by the
compass by the way g4 looking at the f5
square so that this night is not not
coming down but ok Bishop e3 was played
96 yeah this is where we want we want to
be attacking this weakness Bishop Bishop
age three and now Knight to f5 so this
is basically the the the big um go or
that black hat setting up the pieces in
that way oops all looking here and very
nice strategical display by by a
marijuana however how good is this
position for for black yeah like a mu
are now captured on f5 there's probably
not much choice de force under too much
pressure he captured and now the next
move the next move is very very critical
and
I was very surprised that he played that
very surprised um because it basically
in this in a in a strategic sent it's
more or less giving up the game to be
honest you know play deaf form and I
really thought wow really isn't this
like after g4 isn't this like almost
almost lost for white long term yeah to
be honest I believe a white is almost
lost here strategically speaking yes of
course yes no this is a bit much he is
much much worse and it is a very very
one-sided affair yeah we receive how the
game unfolds but here alternatively
there there is this move which seems to
be still okay for white yeah what this
move does is it prevents any f4 idea as
it is covered and if black no captures
on b5 we have Quincy too and this is not
move that upon that black can defend
this still seems to be okay if white
gets this pawn he definitely will we'll
have enough enough play and black and
not defended I mean this move is not not
really good it's I mean it's probably
not the most intuitive way to play but
simply f4 before I play f4i rather do
anything else he played this relatively
quickly I don't know maybe he had some
idea after g4 that was simply not
working out because I think of course my
camera is a much much better player than
I am and it is should be very clear to
him that this is all most strategically
busted for what he needs to be needs to
have some sort of concrete idea why this
would be playable if there is no
concrete idea wider is just getting to
be a yeah getting to be a ground down
slowly there are simply too many
weaknesses we see what have
queen bee three rook c8 yeah intending
look-see for a big light squared
weakness Luke see one Roxy for here we
come and now black has lots of ideas how
to regroup he went an IT to now why did
but yeah we can we can look at some some
stuff like this this was not convincing
as white can capture 97 is better and
now he went 93 and rook c8 this is
better keeping the pressure on them to
take on b5 yeah something something like
this it's not necessary like it's not
not in verse in bad shape here but it's
better to keep the maximum pressure on
ya hear that camera played played age 32
sort of stir up some trouble on the
Kings side and yeah but let's just say
he's playing a passive yeah b5 to defend
a form if we look at this this type of
position black then then has a fantastic
fantastic game let's say like this 98
you want to go here or here 98 let's say
that's something like this why it is
totally paralyzed and then at the end
there's also bishop d 8 a-5 or d 8b 6 so
white will fall apart and give this to a
comp it's minus 21 white will probably
lose some material due to this fantastic
black activity yeah you're always
playing with this tall porn on you three
all pawns on dark squares yeah well
nakamura try to to break out here with
the with h3 but black can simply take
this and now also take v5 he just won
this week pawn it was all in a bit of a
result of this b4 b5 expansion that
didn't really need too much and this
combined with with f4 was probably
really
bit too much to to survive here black
just has this extra pawn this a good
good look on c4 pressure here yeah why
does white has just lost in this
position but it continued for a while
and in fact there was some some
interesting moments though look take see
one quite nice yeah giving up the the
Queen however in this position there
also was an additional idea karana also
could have played Queenie for check here
very very funny move that was even even
more convincing the point is that after
this addy take so I of takes the rook
takes c4 is not possible due to this and
the pawn is promoting quite quite a
funny line this means that yeah after
this this white funny enough has to take
here and after Luke takes we have a
completely winning bishop endgame so
this was was quite nice Queenie for
wrapping things up but taking on c1 is
also winning rookie 6 Fe and now g4 yeah
white has to do something drastic he
cannot just sit and wait yeah and here
we come to to a funny moment here Kara
wanna could have won the game instantly
that probably would have forced instant
resignation and it's not like it's only
he he also must do that he by not doing
it he gives white some counter chances
the great movie is Bishop to H form it's
a very funny move somehow it said just
puts it on a protected square but it's
just strong if white decides to take
their is this rook move coming and the
Queen only has something here on the
second rank after widgets lost very nice
so after this black is winning due to
this thread Roxy to our roots III Roxy
to it's really really a nice move yeah
he took on G forever and now after
Queenie to White has some counter play
it shouldn't be enough but
he has some counterplay now aiming at
Queen 2h7 jak 3 we get to this check
yeah here it seems that Karen is making
mistake the only probably only real miss
mistake he made in the game he played a
king to e8 this is however all very
difficult from a technical point if you
note that he didn't have so much time
here so difficult to calculate against
the Queen King f8 was a what it was
stronger it seems after King hate what
he played it also should be it should be
winning in the long run after King eight
no Nakamura had had a chance to to maybe
draw the game it was very difficult to
level he played f5 which at the end
turned out to be a to be losing but a
king f1 it seems is a is a very strong
move looks a bit strange at this kind of
waiting move but it sets up later at
five and it goes simply simply give us
out of this these ideas it's a little
bit like a prophylactic moose and it
seems that while black now can try to
improve this position he really does not
manage to do so decisively yeah
something like this for example there
squeegee 6 King here and f5 and this is
very serious these are very serious
drawing chances as white may pick up all
those pawns um for instance a line that
that I had looked at is is this until I
think white really is drawing very a
very difficult for black to to get
anywhere here something like this white
activates this bishop
yeah Roxy for we also have this idea
yeah white has very very a substantial
drawing chances after King f1 it's not
it's not so easy to be one hundred
percent sure him if you invest maybe
lots lots of more time but this was a
definite chance after f5 he really is
lost I mean after that we should be for
Jack was ultimately winning check it
check it was stores and some work of
course check but check now black gets
his pieces back and get some
coordination that have poorness stop
Jack White is a back I didn't really
look at the last moves in my analysis so
they went to this point where Nakamura
here resigned the game so it really
happened kawana has won all of his games
five out of five this is really a yeah
maybe one of the most astonishing
performances that they have a word jazz
history I know that Carlton plate plate
tournament in Nanjing once 2009 or 2010
I'm not sure 2009 maybe way can not sure
way where he's got like five out of five
with with white and had four out of five
and the in the in the second turn off of
this event and there was also at Apollo
fever he went six out of seven I think
in the World Championship 2005 in San
Luis some some runs like that but other
than that this is this is simply am
simply fantastic I mean it is fantastic
but this is there are very few results
that are comparable to that you cannot
hear even are not able to calculate his
rating performance as this is impossible
within one hundred percent just
mathematically impossible so it's will
be very difficult for him not to win the
tournament is
and a half points ahead of the field the
field consisting of cars led to power of
no one fifty percent I think the best
that Magnus can try to do is somehow win
the game against Cara wanna with black
to get some sort of yeah some sort of
satisfaction for from this event no not
nothing great of course but to somehow
save this yeah but fantastic and
performance by owned by the Italian
player here yeah I hope you enjoyed the
coverage I felt that it could have been
even more detailed and I couldn't really
get to to some of the finer points and
for example this end game but you have
some limits what you can do in a chest
video and maybe I will look at the end
game later in a separate and separate
coverage yeah I hope you enjoyed it
thanks for watching